- C'est avec une force rarement
vue au Canada que la tempête
Fiona déferle sur l'est du pays.
En Nouvelle-Écosse,
où ell
Fiona a endommagé le réseau
électrique, des stue, des stati-
service, déraciné des arbres
et endom
Celle de ce résident
de Sydney, la plus grande ville
du Cap-Breton, a été endommagée.
La province a d'ailleurs appelé
l'armée en renfort pour l'aider.
Aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine,
les puissants vents ont aussi
couché des poteaux électriques
au sol, renversé des cabanes
et détruit des maisons.
qui... cassaient et je me suis
rendu un petit peu plus loin,
puis le premier chalet, là...
j'ai même vu le frigidaire
sortir puis prendre l'eau.
- Oui, on sentait... couchés,ent
la maison bouger, là.
On sentait littéralement
le 120-140 km/h. On a vuures les
complètement, pas juste
les bardeaux d'asphalte, là,
vraiment la maison au complet.ie
au Nouveau-Brunswick :
des routes inondées,
aussi, des maisons et
dents prêts à évacuer.
- C'est la première fois
On est la seule, je pense,la ser
qui... qui est sous l'eau.
c'est pas mal plus élevé.
On est juste le... on a été
malchanceux de ce côté-là,
l'assurance va couvrir.
- Devant ce qui est considéré
comme une tempête historique
sans précédent, des organismes
d'aide mobilisent du personnel
formé pour nourrir, hydrater,
les premiers intervenants
et les personnes touchées
par la tempête Fiona.
Radio-Canada, Mon